the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
all right my friends it looks like we
have some new information regarding one
of the game of thrones successor shows
that has been in development
if you have been watching all of my
videos then you would know hbo has been
working on several shows for a number of
years
as i'm sure most of you know by now
house of the dragon which is the series
that is based on george rr martin's fire
and blood is already filming scenes for
their first season
however that's not all hbo is working on
in a recent announcement we found out
they were considering
at least three other spin-off shows one
of those shows is about lord corliss
velaryon
and his nine voyages the second one is
about flea bottom
arguably the worst slum in king's
landing and
the third show is about nymeria a name
that you should recognize from game of
thrones because it's what arya stark
named her direwolf
the show about nymeria is what i want to
discuss in this video
according to an article released by
deadline this morning
amanda siegel will be writing the script
for the game of thrones successor show
known as ten thousand ships
for those of you that are not very
familiar with amanda siegel she is known
for her work on other shows like cbs's
the good wife
stephen king's the mist hulu's hellstrom
and much more
this hbo drama is expected to follow the
journey made by warrior queen princess
nymeria and the surviving members of the
rhoynar's
who traveled from essos to dorne
following their defeat by the valyrian
freehold in the second spice war
hbo has yet to give a comment on this
new information but we already knew they
were thinking about making this show so
i think it's safe to assume it's
accurate now based on what we know the
series should be set roughly 1000 years
before the events of game of thrones
if you're not very familiar with this
character i will show you what it says
about her on a wiki of ice and fire just
to give you some of the basic
information
it says nymeria was said to be gorgeous
described by maester yandel as
strong-willed and indomitable
nymeria was said to have cunning skill
and wisdom
although nymeria is remembered as a
warrior queen
and in songs is said to have been a
witch neither statement is accurate
while she did not bear arms in battle
nymeria commanded her armies
leading them on the battlefield she was
a princess of the rhoynar
after the roaring was conquered by the
valyrian freehold
nymeria led the rhoynar to dorne where
she took lord morse martell of the sand
ship as her husband
after years of war and conquest house
nymeros martel
established supremacy of her dorne with
nymeria ruling for well over two decades
as the princess
through nymeria's rule the dornish
adopted many rhornish customs and laws
that remain to this day
now it also says this series will be
about what happens during the second
spice war
so let me show you what it says about
that as well during the second spice war
prince garin united the rhoynar nobility
in a grand alliance against the valerian
freehold
only nymeria spoke out against him
warning the other princes that they
could not win the war
however these other princes shouted her
down and joined their strength to prince
garan
and even nymeria's own warriors were
eager to join his cause
now despite her own reluctance nymeria
found herself forced to join the great
alliance as well
despite garen's initial success against
the freehold
the valerians responded by sending 300
dragons against the rhoynar
garin's host was shattered and he was
eventually captured
nymeria learned of garen's defeat in the
enslavement of her people
and she knew that her city awaited the
same fate in response
she gathered every ship that remained
upon the ruin and filled them with as
many women
and children as they could carry most of
the men had died alongside garen's host
while legends often state that nymeria
commanded a fleet of ten thousand ships
beltacar argues in his history of the
rhoynish wars
that the number was inflated maybe even
by tenfold
while other chroniclers offer other
numbers in all honesty no count was ever
made
maester yandell agrees that nymeria led
a great many ships
mostly rivercraft skiffs trading galleys
fishing boats rafts and barges crammed
with women
children and old men only one in 10 was
actually seaworthy beltakar insisted
nymeria led her ragged fleet down the
royne around ruined towns and fields of
corpses
now in order to avoid volantis and the
dragonlords
nymeria chose an older channel and
emerged into the summer sea where the
city of sarhoy once stood
the following voyage was long and awful
and more than a hundred ships sank in
the first storm they encountered
as many or more were taken by fear and
turned back
only to be captured by the slavers out
of atlantis
others fell behind or drifted away and
were never seen again
nymeria wandered these southern seas for
about three years
during that time she lost many more of
her followers and supporters
some of them died from starvation
disease or even slavers
finally nymeria went west like arya
stark only not as far
and the remnants of her fleet settled in
the deserts of dorne on westeros
her less seaworthy ships settled the
stepstones or gave themselves up to the
slavers of the free cities
nymeria in her ships finally made
landfall on the coast of dorne
near the mouth of the river greenblood
not far from the sandship
the ancient seat of house martel when
nymeria arrived in dorne
many viewed the rhoynar as unwelcome
invaders who should be driven back into
the sea
however lord morse martel of the sand
ship saw an opportunity in the rhoynar
and singers claimed that the lord martel
also fell in love with nymeria with many
trained in warfare
the rhoynar added their strength to lord
martel's own
increasing his hosts by tenfold he
married nymeria
and hundreds of his knights squires and
bannermen
wed rhoynish women uniting them all by
blood
the rhoynar also brought considerable
wealth with them
and their artisans in armor skills were
far
advanced than those in westeros as a
celebration of these unions
and to ensure that her people could not
retreat back to the sea
nymeria burned her fleet declaring her
wanderings to be in an end
however some of her people mourned the
loss of the ships nymeria named her
husband the prince of dorne
declaring his dominion over all of dorne
however
such supremacy was not an easy feat and
years of war
followed which is known as nymeria's war
the rhoynar
and the martel subdued one petty king
after another
and no fewer than six kings were sent to
the wall to join the night's watch
soon after only king yorick yornwood
remained
the greatest of the dornish kings for
nine years
nymeria and the martells battled against
yornwood and his bannermen
when her husband fell to yornwood sword
in the third battle of the boneway
nymeria assumed sole command of the
martel armies
several more years of battle followed
but nymeria eventually defeated yorick
and he bent the knee to her ensuring
martell supremacy
nymeria ruled thereafter from sunspear
the new seat of house martel
built around sandship now there's
obviously more information in the books
about nymeria but i just wanted to give
you an idea of what we might see in the
show
that is if it's ever officially made
into a series
for now they are still in the very early
stages of development
although this story is set in george rr
martin's a song of ice and fire universe
i think it would have a much different
feel to it than game of thrones or even
house of the dragon
this show would not focus on what is
considered to be the four major houses
of westeros
hal stark house targaryen house
lannister and house baratheon
not only that but this series would not
be set in king's landing
nor would it focus on the iron throne as
a matter of fact balerion would not
forge the iron throne for another 700
years
it would also have a female lead as its
main character
you might either love or hate this idea
depending on what you like about a song
of ice and fire
now in my opinion there are a lot of
other stories i would rather get seen
brought to life
before this one but i don't dislike the
idea either
as i have said before i will watch
anything adapted from george rr martin's
novel so long as it's good
let me know what all of you think about
this new information down below
i would love to see what you have to say
i want to thank everyone for stopping by
and watching the video
hopefully i will see all of you come
back for my next game of thrones season
9 episode that will be out soon
have a great day everyone i will see you
soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you